the struggle of finding workers for
certain business is really continuing in
and around las vegas tonight victoria
saha telling us why a restaurant has to
close their doors twice a week now
so their current workers are not
overwhelmed
the kitchen staff at juan's flaming
fanitas in the southwest valley and
tropicana near fort apache
is busy at work doing the best they can
with limited staff
we've asked them to pick up the extra
shifts to work the extra hours and
they've more than obliged to do that
because they want to see us continue to
grow
now on mondays and tuesdays the kitchen
and restaurant will have their lights
off
give them an opportunity to have some
downtime and spend some time with their
family
earlier this week they put out a
statement saying they will close two
days out of the week
to lessen the burden on their exhausted
staff probably the past six months
we've had very minimal applicants coming
in so
that's kind of what's led to it's not
just a couple weeks of picking up extra
it's been continued months
of them working those extra ships to
give you a better understanding of the
staffing shortage here
the manager says on average they used to
have 110 employees
right now they're down to 85. sometimes
having to bring in staff from their
henderson location to help kitchen
manager claudio carlos is one of the
staff that decided to stick around
everybody working more time so now he
never got time for spending time with
his
family and everything that was
something hard for everybody he says
he's staying because the owners are
valuing their staff with the two days
off
the restaurant has a referral program if
an employee brings in a new staff member
they each get 250 dollars victoria zaha
8 news now
victoria thanks now they don't know when
they'll reopen again on mondays and
tuesdays they need people they're hoping
as soon as they are fully staffed they
can get back to normal business hours
if you would like to apply link up on
our website 8newsnow.com a lot of jobs
out there